this is a production of Cornell
University
it's pruning season and I wanted to show
you what the vine looks like before we
prune during prune and after pruning so
this is a pretty standard grapevine here
for the fingerless we're in a Riesling
block this is called a double Gyo or a
two-tier flat bow system so this one's a
clean prune vine and so here's our first
clone that comes out this is another
cone and from our cones we grew the
shoots right here these are some nice
shoots and on the shoots our buds and so
basically our fruiting zone was right
through here so our our Bloods would
have gone leaf leaf and then cluster
cluster and you can see where some
clusters came off here and then it would
go up from there so up above here this
was all leaf area our fruit was in here
hidden in some leaves so now what we
need to do is prune booze so that we are
laying out some clones again for this
year so I'm going to move up the row
here I prepare to bind and cut out a
little bit of the stuff around it so
that you can get for you what we're
doing so here's a vine that I'm
preparing for pulling so what we want to
do is get rid of these old tones and we
need to lay down new cones so that
they'll produce shoots this year so
we're gonna look at what we have that's
going to be decent for laying down and I
missed those
this wood is quite poor I just snapped
it as I was bringing it around the wire
but it has gray wood that's up here and
so that means that the tone is basically
dead or is in very poor shape so this is
not going to work to be a time to lay
down there because none of that is going
to grow that's all gray when you cut
through there so that's not going to
work for me to lay it down so we're
looking for something to lay down here I
don't particularly want to use this one
for two reasons one is that it's
thickened diameter this is what we call
bull wood and we want something that's a
little more narrow like this the second
reason is that this is quite far out
from this region that we call the head
of the vine and if we use this one then
we'll have no fruit production along
this area so that's not great either so
basically there's nothing on this clone
that I can use so I'm gonna cut it out
we don't need any of this down here so
I'm just gonna get rid of some of this
clean it up and get it out of here and
get rid of the rest of this you
considered actually entwines into the
neighboring vine so that's gone and what
we're gonna have to do is find something
else to lay down in its place and in
this post this might be a pretty decent
choice it's got some nice paradigm as we
would say this nice brown wood along
here and would probably tie out
reasonably well here eject a little
grill at the end but it might be our
best choice I think for what's gonna go
along here so for now I'm gonna go like
this
and get rid of this gray stuff at the
end so that's one cane now we need to
lay out another clone along this
fruiting wire this one looks not too bad
a little speckled a little thicker than
I would like but we don't really have
any good options left here so I'm gonna
get rid of this cut off this old :
your day let me move out of the way by
cutting and that one's gone the plans
going to be to live this one down got to
get it through our catch wires here got
a clip on our wires so this one's
clearly a little long it goes into the
next vine so I'm going to snip that off
there so that will go down along that
wire this one along here so moving to
the other side of the vine we're looking
for some time to lay down we cut this
one off already we've got some nice gray
wood here that we know is not going to
produce very good buds or shoots it's
actually got some spots from film ops
Asst right along the claim here and so
that is probably why the clone is mostly
dead so in this case we're looking for
two cones that are close to the head of
the vine that we can lay down on these
fruiting wires so lex's this one does
not look too bad
that one is gray at the top so that's
not gonna be very good and then this one
cuts out a little bit far so in this
case I think this is probably my best
shot I'll get this out of there
and so then I'll live this one down
along here now we need I came for on the
other side neither of these is perfect
again this one gets more grey towards
the top but this one is a little bit
bigger with longer internodes so hard to
decide exactly what to use here I think
I'd probably go for this one so in this
case I'm gonna cut this off clean up
this mess you can see this is all dead
wood it's had some offices on it this
comes from the neighbor and vine so I'm
going to and this here there's actually
a really really long chute so we've left
this one as a potential trunk renewal so
often our trucks will get damaged from
the cold in the Finger Lakes region we
normally leave a couple of trunks so
that we have a backup if one got damaged
we've still got another one we've left
this here in case we want to replace one
of the trunks in this case it's not
necessary there's no visible damage
there having said that when there's cold
damage on the trunk it can often show up
a couple of years later but this is
actually this huge chute that comes up
and across here so I'm gonna get rid of
this whole thing cut it out of the way
I'm gonna leave a butt down here though
so that we can use this as a potential
renewal again so the butt at the bottom
here will grow into another chute that
will grow up and then if we want to
replace the trunk next year we'll have
that so let me cut this out and I'll
show you what this is gonna look like
so I'm gonna cut off the top of this
because it's longer than renewed so this
is going to be our tune for this side
and then this one again is longer than
removed and it's really big here at the
top but this is going to be our cone
that wraps along this fruit and wire
right here so this is a keen pruned vine
now so we've got our four cones one two
three four
I'm each of these has a series of nodes
on them right here at each node is a bud
and these buds are going to grow into
shoots and those shoots are going to
produce group grapes this growing season
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu